there's four types of people in the
world the wrong ones can ruin your life
the right ones can improve your life the
key is to be aware of the four type and
knowing which ones you gotta cut out of
your life and which ones you got to go
and get more of in your life today we're
going to talk about those four different
types of people in your life
[Music]
okay so let's get right into it for them
by the way if you get value from this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel for types subtract those
who divide those who add those who
multiply very obvious subtract they take
away from you they never give anything
to you they always take they take away
from your energy they're negative you
feel exhausted after you around them
these are these subtract people in your
life number two is divide they always
have a wedge between you and somebody
else in a relationship in a work
environment if your boss is a divide
person they're gonna be distancing you
from people above you because God forbid
if they find out that you're really
better than him you may pass them up
that is a person that's a divider right
they'll go he always Shields me from
everybody else it could be in
friendships it could be in relationships
it could be in many different places
that they divide they always come in
between you and your friends they always
come in between you and your siblings
they come in between your new appearance
this happens politically this happens
organizationally this happens in a
family it happens everywhere so so far
we've covered too subtract divide third
one add those who add to you you're
around them you feel better hey did you
read this book hey did you see what
happened here I really like what you got
going on hey you look good today they're
adding hey a thing you may want to
consider doing this it's constantly
adding to help you improve they're
adding to your life number four is those
who multiply somehow some way when
you're around them you get better
strategies you get into better circles
that provide other opportunities that
all of a sudden you get into an
investment you make a million two you
got connected with this one place they
say hey here's what I'm doing with this
investment you may want to look into it
here's what I'm doing with this part of
my job you may want to look into this
and your ability to do anything gets
better you lead better you sell better
you negotiate better you add it better
you Dr everything becomes better because
they're sharing that part with you so
gradually you're becoming a better
leader by the way in the marketplace
those who add and multiply their market
value always increases those who
subtract and divide they gradually go
from one organization they find somebody
to blame they go to the next
organization they find somebody to blame
there's always a problem no matter where
they go they keep going to a new place
new place new place now let's go to you
it's easy for you to watch this content
and to say well let me tell you the
reason why I'm not winning is because
there's a person in my life that's a
divider what if you're the divider what
if you're the one that's right what if
somebody shared this video with you and
they didn't want to tell you this but
they shared it with you you're the
actual divider you're the one that
subtract and you say no never me I would
never do it really no problem here's how
to measure whether you are a subtract
divide or whether you're a multiplier
and an ad the people in someone's life
who keep winning around that person's
life that person is probably a
multiplier I was watching documentary
the other day about a person that did
very well in media and everybody around
him got better on media their show got
better everything they did was better
because he was a multiplier somehow some
way everybody improved in sports a coach
who multiplies better coaches around him
who go out there and win that's a
multiplier right in business somebody
who or people around them start making
more money their life improves that's a
multiplier in a mentor of a father
figure that develops other men that
become good Fathers that is a multiplier
typically it's very easy to figure out
who's a multiplier and who's somebody
that adds based on the people around
them winning it it's also very easy to
see if people around someone are
dividers and subtractors because of what
happens in people in their lives if
people in your life are constantly going
through fallouts and issues and negative
and all this stuff there's probably
someone in your life or you that's
attracted to that step number one to
this is self-awareness whether we know
it or not we have to ask the question if
the way you lead gets no results you're
probably following this category or you
don't have a better hack so now here's
the other part some people say oh my God
so what do I do I got to present it to
my life that's a divider or a subtractor
what do I do about this you know if
you're the one that's leading them you
have a shout out doing something with it
if you're in a place where they're
leading you where you may have a problem
there but let me explain this part to
you if somebody has body odor but they
don't know you don't tell them they're
going to continue having body odor if
somebody has body odor you tell them
listen you got body odor they change or
maybe they were oblivious to it but now
they change they no longer have a body
odor if somebody is negative and they
don't know it but they're like that
because their mom was like that their
dad was like that their brother was like
that their former boss was like that and
they're divider and say hey John I just
want to talk to you about something here
I've seen a handful of things that
happen here that I get a feeling you're
negative and when you are negative you
divide different departments I want to
bring this up to you are you aware of
this oh really yeah we like you I think
long term you can do some or a friend
dude I like you you're my friend we've
known each other for seven years yeah
but yeah but yeah I don't think that's
what they want yeah you typically go to
negative 10 and quite frankly it's
bringing the energy down amongst the
friends are you aware of this dude I'm
not aware of this you're open to the
idea of working on this of course I am
and if they do well guess what they were
oblivious you pointed it out but if that
keeps continuing to happen that's the
moment where you got to cut some
relationships out of your life
specifically the subtractors and
dividers let me explain to you why
something might say that doesn't make
any sense let's say you got five people
in your life Investments you got five
Investments one investment makes you 20
every year the other one makes you 25
the other one makes you thirty percent
the other one makes you 35 all of them
are evenly you got 100 Grand 20 20 20 20
20. one page 20 25 30 35 but the last
one loses you 80 every year you know
what ends up happening it doesn't matter
that these four Investments are doing
well this one's sucking up your rate of
reach it's areas like this in your life
where you can't say well let me make an
exception for this no no you're losing
money on this investment it's time to
sell this off and bring another
relationship in here it's hurting your
organization your relationship your life
your family same exact way you look at
Investments is the same exactly you got
to look at relationships either you're
pouring into them they're pouring into
you or you're taking from them and
they're taking from you you got to make
a decision what you need to do there so
if you got value from the video give it
a thumbs up subscribe to the channel got
another video I want you to watch is how
to identify who's a running mate
relationship that may be a long-term
relationship potentially running mate if
you've never seen that before click here
to watch the video take everybody bye
bye
foreign